in this video we'll talk about the
morphogen gradient this is a fundamental
Concept in developmental biology and not
properly explained anywhere so
morphogens are diffusible biochemical
molecules that can determine the
cellular fate and this sulfate
determination depends on the
concentration magnitude and timing of
the morphogen so this is the source cell
in green that secretes several molecules
shown by these green dots and that can
be received by nearby cells which would
be patterned eventually so they are the
responder cells
and we can obviously understand the
concentration of molecules are more
towards the source than the end of the
responders
and based on these concentration there
could be different outcome in cellular
fate let's say fate number one fit
number two or fit number three and all
of these can possibly depend on the
morphogen concentration and the
signaling that is evoked by the
morphogen
so how morphogen gradient can influence
sulphate specification let's understand
that part
cells that are exposed to high level of
morphogen can activate a several set of
genes
and the cells that are exposed to lower
levels of morphogen that can also
activate a different set of genes and
thereby two different Fates are evoked
so obviously let's say based on the
concentration of morphogen there could
be different transcriptional or Gene
regulatory program that can be activated
that might lead to fate number one when
we have intermediate concentration of
morphogen that might lead to fate number
two when we have let's say very less
concentration of morphogen that might
activate a completely different set of
transcriptional module that lead to fate
number three this is how we can
understand how morphogen gradient is
kind of interpreted we would elaborate
on that
but let's talk about in details how the
responder cells can interpret the
message embedded in the morphogen
gradient
but before that let's try to understand
what is the defining criteria
to understand a morphogen how do we say
that this particular molecule is a
morphogen so there are multiple criteria
the particular molecule or morphogen has
to be present at the right time in the
right place
second morphogen should be shown to
released from a localized source so
these localized Source in context of
mammals are known as signaling centers
which are specialized group of cells
which can secrete morphogens
also ah
basically there could be two or
different more than two Pathways or Gene
activatory program should be changed
during this morphogen exposure
also over an under expression of
morphogen might lead to a predictable
change all of these criteria would
Define what a morphogen is
now let's talk about interpretation of
the morphogene gradient
so morphogen gradient can Shape Up
Cellular fate and the understanding lies
in different levels so first of all
morphogen secretion leads to uh plethora
of changes Downstream for example let's
say there are specific tissue specific
transcription factors or transcriptional
modulators which is present in one cell
type not not versus other can give rise
to different outcomes so that leads to a
tissue specific competence
there could be morphogen dynamics that
means the signal inside the morphogen
could be interpreted differentially
based on space and time
so it matters how much a cell is
experiencing a morphogen and the
absolute magnitude of this
and all this thing is changing our
transcriptional module eventually which
leads to change in sulfate as we can see
so basically we can imagine sulphate
specification in a three different stage
Factor like first morphogen induction
then the interpretation of the morphogen
signal and the outcome is fed
determination
now interpretation of the morphogen
gradient is quite difficult and also the
morphogen secretion kinetics could be
complicated for example if we consider
these green cells who are secreting
morphogens they can secrete the
morphogen in a steady state level over
time that means they are fairly
secreting this particular morphogene in
a constant rate
there are other possibilities like it it
is secreting the morphogens in a
pulsatile manner over time so it's a
Time variant secretion there could be
possibilities like time dependent
increase in secretion or time dependent
decrease in secretion based on the
secretion kinetics the response kinetics
would be also different
and together the secretion and the
response kinetics can shape up the
downstream processes and lead to
different cellular fate
now let's talk about some examples of
morphogens
and many examples come from the fruit
fly in the fruit fly in the context of
wing development one of the very
important morphogen is DPP the DPP
gradient determines the uh several win
Wing components
So based on this DPP gradient in about
50 hours of time there are specific gene
expression such as Sal and OMB and as we
move far away from the DPP Source
OMB is only expressed and based on these
differential gene expression different
fate is chosen along the wing so in the
mature Wing the anterior Wing blade and
the posterior Wing blade is
differentiated just by the DPP gradient
now we can get another example from
xenopus
in xenopus
embryo we can see the active in and xnr
gradient leads to specification of
specific structures so this is the
animal widget and the vegetal pole that
means the anterior posterior pole and
the dots of ventral Pole in that
particular region there is a new Coupe
Center which is a signaling Center which
can secrete active in an xnr
this kind of morphogen shape up
different gene expression in different
region so from the dorsal to ventral
region there are differences in gene
expression that lead to eventually
acquisition of different fate so the
dorsalmos region
now becomes notochord or spement Center
the lateral region becomes muscle cells
and the ventral most region produces
blood cells so now there are different
outcomes shaped by the morphogen
gradient
now let's talk about experiments that
demonstrate the morphogen gradient
activity
so there are experiments done on Cell
cultures where on a sheath of cells some
beads soaked in active in was placed so
there were four nanomolars of activein
and in a control experiment only beads
without any morphogen was placed and it
was left for several uh hours and after
few days it was observed that
there are differences in terms of gene
expression
in the active in soaked bead and this
has a positional effect that means the
cells which are immediately uh close to
the active in bead shows expression of
goose coid Gene and the cells which are
slightly away from the active in bead
shows XBR expression that means just by
changing the distance from the morphogen
different genes can be expressed in
different Fates can be acquired
so overall this can be understood in
format of graph
just by changing the distances different
Fates can be achieved because
different cells can experience the
morphogen in a different level and for
different duration of time
so there could be concept of gene
expression threshold that means certain
amount of activity is required for let's
say uh expressing the xbra Gene and that
threshold is let's say higher for the
goose squared Gene so that is why cells
which are absolutely close to the beads
basically lead to express Express the
goose quite Gene because that has higher
threshold and the cells which are very
far away they express the Xperia Gene
because it has low threshold so there
are gene expression threshold which adds
a layer of complexity in terms of
understanding sulphate specification
now let me tell you the complication we
are only thinking morphogen is secreted
and that morphogen is received by the
nearby cells it's not the only thing
that happens there could be other
antagonist molecule which is
counteracting the activity of these
morphogens so there could be a counter
gradient of Inhibitors and this has been
seen in the development of ventral nerve
tube patterning so in the ventral nerve
tube there is notochord which is a
source of morphogen SSH
or Sonic Hedgehog so Sonic Hedgehog has
a gradient from ventral side to the
dorsal side
also glie which is a responder has a
similar gradient and this is expected
but there is a Glee inhibitor or Glee
repressor which has a opposite gradient
and that shapes up how the progenitor
cells would experience the SSH signaling
and that lead to different outcomes this
signaling Dynamics is interpreted
differentially in space and time that
lead to differences in transcription
factor expression Master regulated
expression which leads to different fate
along the
lots of internal axis
now let's talk about what are the
molecular mechanisms which can possibly
lead to changes how actually morphogens
can work so let's say this signal is
acting as a morphogen it can work like a
auto regulatory feedback loop so signal
is giving rise to or activating a
transcription factor which is auto
activating itself so it's working like a
feed forward Loop this kind of signaling
mechanism is common it's happening in
the vertebrate uh neural tube
development so where the roof plate or
the dorsal side is secreting wind and
wind is the signal and the transcription
Factor here is the Pax 3. Pax 3 is auto
regulating its own expression by a feed
forward Loop this feed forward Loop
could be bit more complicated so there
could be Cascade feed forward blue in
this Cascade feed forward Loop the
product of the previous Gene help the
expression of the next Gene so basically
it basically works like an amplifier
now there could be mutual repression
Mutual depression means signal induces
two transcription Factor but each of
these transcription Factor mutually
repress their own activity and that lead
to Sharp tissue boundaries that means
the protein level would be dropping
sharply at a particular boundary and
this this is an important factor to
create specific segments in across a
body line
so mutual depression is very important
to understand how morphogens can
possibly work and the last thing which
is more complicated and involves all of
the previous mentioned uh strategies is
basically a transcription Factor Network
which can have like all these Auto
regulatory feedback loop there could be
having feed forward loops and also
Mutual repression acting together as a
network this is how we can understand
how possibly a morphogen can work and
shape up development of specific tissues
into specialized cell types
I hope this was useful if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe you
can get more notes and flashcard in my
Facebook page Instagram you can support
my channel via PayPal paytm and UPI see
you in next video